[Music]
let's talk about aliens
yes i've been waiting for this one
thank you i have two different stories
here so the first one is
and this is like i guess a tiny little
bit of old news by now but it's okay
an ex-israeli space off a space official
says that aliens exist and they even
have a
galactic federation yes does he have a
selfie with one
no how is he so what are the
federation's names what all the the
names
because he was a space dude right so
that's why he should know the secrets
he's the guy that used to run
israel's space progress space security
okay they had a space program
you know it's legit is if they tried to
discredit him did anyone try to
discredit him
uh i think so i think they gave up now
and how come there's all this space
news but no one's flipping out about it
like let's
see we can't we're not allowed to so he
actually so he's 87 years old by the way
and he worked for the israeli government
from 81 to 2010
and he alleges that president trump was
about to blow the lid off the whole
thing recently but that he was convinced
to not say anything because most humans
weren't ready for the truth
they just banned his accounts on
facebook and twitter yep
um if anyone was going to blow the
whistle it would have been trump
i think so too and then also that that
he's an entertainer kind of guy people
are saying like that's why he
was so adamant about creating space
sports
the space supports oh because they told
him about aliens and he's like we got to
fight those [ __ ]
i could see us attack he's like we gotta
be
ready for those [ __ ] yeah so then
people are like well why is he
coming why is he coming out with this
now if he worked
like over 10 years ago right come on
people god [ __ ] that's the stupidest
question
[ __ ] time he says that it's all about
timing
if he had brought this up five years ago
he would have been written off as nuts
he's like independence day
part five didn't come out yet but people
are still
calling like writing him off and being
like nah he's old he's senile he's crazy
because like i said he is 87 years old
this is what he looks like
after he saw the bob lazar documentary
that's when he was like
now it's time for me the second one yeah
so yeah
that's pretty crazy right i'm gonna be a
little ignorant right now but was that
jewish writing or was that alien writing
i think it was english in a font
is real hebrew oh it's not the hebrew
right
oh i thought it was english in the font
we're both ignorant for all we know it's
originally
alien writing that we learned we don't
[ __ ] know could it be
we don't know is shed wasn't
hebrew like one of the original
languages or something sounds like it
so that was the first the first story
thing right and then the second one
is that a harvard for a harvard
professor
says that back in 2017 when there was
like that real
really strange cigar-shaped object that
yeah went past the our solar system it's
like super metallic looking or something
close to earth too
the holy hawaiian name yes that one uh
oh we thought it was like an asteroid
the flying portuguese and then actually
it actually shifted it moved right
um weird thing about it was that it
it's an interstellar object that
actually shifted like it made a move
yes and it also it accelerated at a
certain point
but and so they were thinking like maybe
it's a comet like it's probably a comet
you could see it came out out of our
solar system came through our solar
system
but the fact that it um it actually like
changed this trajectory and all that
this one professor from harvard is
saying that
that is like a clear sign that this
has some sort of intelligence behind it
it's not a natural
occurrence i trust it because it's
harvard and it's not ancient aliens yeah
don't question it anymore
yeah so he believes that this this
object here which this is the image that
was circulating
everywhere on the internet that looks
like doo doo so he's the alien
captain in that ship yeah that's the
harvard professor
but so he says that it could either be
this or
the way that it was reading it could
either be like this type of shape or a
sail like a because it said like it was
like millimeters thick
and um and so it could have gotten
propelled through the sun and pretty
much people were saying that this could
be an alien probe and that more are
going to come in the future
or what he says is he thinks it's just
garbage
from like some residue garbage that just
so happened to land in our
in our solar system and the civilization
behind this probably is long gone by now
but if we can find more garbage or we
can find more clues to other
civilizations
it could give us an insight in what
happened to their civilization and why
they don't exist anymore if they don't
exist anymore and how we can prevent the
same [ __ ] happen
happening to us it could be alien
garbage there was also
um uh new york times did a thing about
how the u.s government has recovered
alien craft
uh it was just a couple months ago and
um
and they they basically were confirmed
from two different sources inside the
government that they have recovered
these craft
like over the years one wasn't found in
an archaeological dig
the other was recovered from a crash
like roswell kind of situation they
didn't say it was roswell
and so yeah all this is kind of stacking
up at the same time which is which is
why i think the
israeli guys like i can talk about this
without just being seen as a complete
crackpot right now
because obviously colonel favor came out
on joe rogan's show and he
he was the first guy in like in our
military
who was like yeah i saw this [ __ ] with
my eyes and we all don't know what the
[ __ ] why does why do they think that
people are not ready
because we're dumb and we're going to be
fighting for toilet paper when code
would first happen
like that's how we're that's what
they're dealing with it upends
everything it happens like religion
too no but they'll find a reason to make
it fit
like religion involves with the times
but i'm telling you why they think
oh like it's too sudden like dude you
could have a gray-headed alien
and the biggest jesus freak next like
like could be like yo this is
they created us and the jesus freak
would would like figure
out how he looked similar to jesus
they'd be like jesus created them
you know what i mean you just don't know
people and people if they really are
that way
this would upend a lot of things that
some of my religious family members told
me that
the dinosaurs were created as uh
tools for humans to use like the
flintstones
by god like the flintstones how fun
like the flintstones they'll make [ __ ]
up yeah they're
good no no why don't they broadcast this
on like
uh mainstream media they did they do
yeah yeah they did they have
but it's overshadowed by yeah everything
else that's happening
but they didn't and people were like
yeah and then people were like
hello like we're talking about real [ __ ]
and then and they don't
do it as silly anymore like the when
they used to talk about it they play the
x-files theme first and then everyone's
kind of laughing about it
and like yeah they saw this ufo over
phoenix but nowadays it's
it's more um because of i think a lot of
this stuff people are more like
open-minded starting to be open-minded
maybe in the next decade we'll for sure
find out they're like okay
i think humanity they can handle this
[ __ ] what do you think it would happen
what would you think would happen to
humans though
if this came true or like if if like
do you think there'll be all that war
panic oh well i forgot to mention with
the first
dude the israeli guy he says that aliens
are already working with us governments
and that they signed a contract
to do they they signed a contract with
us to do experiments here
because they too are researching and
trying to understand the whole fabric of
the universe
they want us as helpers they believe in
contracts and [ __ ] i know that's i was
like
do they have ballpoint pens and [ __ ]
uranus or something
they're probably like this is what the
humans uh yeah
yeah for an agreement that they'll
commit to it if it's like this
like why would they honor an agreement
because they know we
our litigious society who's more
litigious than america
i don't know i'm just thinking about
they could do whatever the [ __ ] they
want
yeah why do they honor us because we
have resources
they could take it but it's like they
want to study people that's the same
[ __ ]
i guess they could still take us why do
we study fish and stuff like why do we
study ants and all all kinds of you guys
also see that one video clip
with obama and stephen
colbert yeah i saw it we'll know what
they do i'll show you well obama says
there's aliens
no any ufos did you ask about that
certainly asked about it and
i can't tell you sorry okay
all right i'll take that as a yes
because
there was none right you just played
your hand i thought you were a poker
player
you just 100 showed your river card feel
feel free to think that
i don't that's so much
it makes me happy to thank you tell me
about it can i say it used to be
that ufos was the uh and uh what is it
roswell was the biggest conspiracy
yeah and now that seems so tame right
right the idea
that right the government might have an
alien spaceship
that's now the biggest conspiracy is
people in michigan vote
well that was that was like last month
that's almost like him saying
yeah it's normalized now right yeah
exactly
or it could be taken as like need to
know basis
i'd have to kill you if i told you like
i don't know well clinton's kind of done
the same thing over the years he's
flirted around the topic
like pretty big time yeah that is crazy
but what are the consequences
like i want to see an impulsive
politician and maybe that's why a lot of
people liked
trump because he would just blurt [ __ ]
out and then so like what he's not
supposed to
yeah he'll be like there are [ __ ]
aliens man get over it already [ __ ] i
want someone to just
make a mistake like that there's no way
they told trump though because he would
have blurred that [ __ ] out
because he blurted out the military
industrial complex yeah he talked about
the military industrial complex all the
time there's no way he he wouldn't have
talked about previously
maybe that was they'd be like trump
really this time you can't talk about it
he's like okay fine he's on the news
he's like aliens
oh [ __ ] sorry you know i just don't buy
that he wouldn't spill it i don't buy it
the guy has no filter yeah why would he
not spill
just this one thing you know what i mean
he's done everything maybe he was
promised something like oh you can um
go meet them if you just don't tell
anyone all right
i don't know i have a lot of gold and
he's like oh [ __ ]
i like gold he's like he plates
everything in gold he even has like a
golden toilet
i don't know i want to meet an alien but
also if
aliens were to be real and whatever and
it becomes mainstream i don't think it
would change my life that much
okay do you think you have already met
an alien do you think
no but i have heard from trying to tell
us the alien people
they're like they're not the people but
people that are like obsessed with it
like they're shape-shifting [ __ ]
they think everyone in media or like the
higher positions
are aliens they call them something
right shape-shifters shape-shifting
reptilian [ __ ]
those guys aren't in the media though oh
maybe they are yeah i don't know
i don't remember what they're called
white something i forgot what it was i
don't remember
white walkers you think aliens are
amongst us already is that what we're
saying well that's what everyone's
saying
yeah and that they're you know they're
working with the higher levels but the
alien people like the people that are
asian aliens if they're just
aliens they they say they always say
that they're working in the media
already
as you see these youtube videos where
they try to catch them shape-shifting in
the middle of their
news reports because all the news
anchors are aliens
that's just plaque plastic surgery
funniest thing about all this though is
that
up until recently we were the only
country that didn't confirm
that we had ufo programs and all [ __ ]
and we saw this
we saw this kind of stuff like mexico
did the uk did like
all these countries did for years like
we're talking like 20 years back even
and now only until recently and that's
how [ __ ] into ourselves we are as
americans
we're like well we don't believe in the
americas but now it's kind of because
america
is the only western country that is
still
devoutly religious so it's still
got those kind of ties we're like the
rest of europe and whatever they're just
kind of like and secular
yeah it could be it could very much be
that way so then
the fabric of our like i guess
countries philosophy can crumble if
the whole religion part is kind of hurt
i feel like
other countries that are are just us or
probably more
yeah just in america too their form of
christianity is much different from ours
theirs is more like ritualistic in
system
is they were uk yeah or like well maybe
not italy because like if you go
within south america or you know i'm
talking about europe oh
yeah yeah because they're more secular
and like
uh liberal in a way where you can
be non-religious but in america it's
still a
very religious country like we still
pray in our government and do all these
things and when we inaugurate new
presidents like the system still has a
lot of
religious aspects to it whereas like
europe has
mexico came out with came out with it
because they're
pretty religious yeah i didn't even know
they had a space program
remember in south park because they use
mexico's space program to send the whale
to space
oh it's so funny no to send a whale to
[Music]
space
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you